why do you like packs okay this is why I
like PI so much pastry dough filling hot
flaky
[Music]
we're in china town about to eat some
pie because i'm gonna eat pies from
around the world rep in China where I'm
from Beijing pie house the word pie is
in the title that means that there's
gonna be tiger
[Music]
hi I don't think this is gonna be like
an American knife and fork bag
obviously so let us see what we get
hi time hashtag world of I look like
platinum giant dumplings
this seems weird here we go hot hot hot
pocket that's delicious
it's delicious that does not even soy
sauce at all that is very tasty high
dose should be flaky let me tell you if
it has that not verdict is delicious
confused as to whether or not it's no
fight I just got some spinach pie I'm
gonna eat it the way everyone should eat
spinach pie in the car
whoa now this is a lot of spinach pie
here we go ador so that's my firm where
I need to be no I don't
[Music]
I never well then delicious let's open
our minds more does I have to be like no
that's what we learned from China just I
have to the circular spherical No
[Music]
verdict is good I like Greek pie
[Music]
well I don't have to introduce what this
is because I think everyone is familiar
with quiche
I consider this apply because it has a
crust
this one has zucchini and red pepper and
feta Google Translate quiche means
quiche that's a joke from natural
influence Europe indication why did she
fall for that that's like I knew that I
knew that already that quiche means
quiche this is good let's see if the
crust is is tasty as the fillings mm-hmm
buttery flaky you know those little
noodles you get those extra noodles you
get with Chinese takeout kind of days
like that a little bit this is the
tastiest so far I think we're gonna have
to stop for today so I can finish this
entire pipe and then we'll come back and
do three more as you can tell it's day
two more different clothes we're gonna
get more Pike
[Music]
day two world of high this is a chicken
potpie from Australia I know today we're
inside I notice I word it but I can
taste savoriness waiting for me inside
hi can you see what's inside
ooh you see chicken it's sea vegetables
I see potatoes this is an entire meal
that's enough pie part that's sort of
like a muffin too
and with a little bit of trouble here
verdict is very good I would love to eat
this for dinner I think it's a good sign
when your man's look like this
afterwards when they're filled with
buttery crumbs
[Music]
I think that's a good time to so now
we're at Stella Barra which is in
Hollywood and we're gonna get a piece of
pie to represent Italy that roasted
garlic yes roasted garlic and green
chillies
how many minutes right now probably
about 10 to 12 minutes okay I'll see you
in 10 to 12 minutes friend Thank You
supply
repeat hello we knew you when you were
just dough is this
I don't care honestly don't know what
I've noticed about all of these pies is
that they all have crust
maybe that's what defines a pie that it
has to have pressed dough surrounding a
filling crack that code this is downtown
LA we're about to go to the pie hole for
the Americans hi checking my hair here
looks good
the final stop we're in downtown LA
we're at the pie hole and I ordered an
Escalade
I like up the apples are really sweet
but very tart it's a little crisp not
mushy at all
that's a nice dress
ee-ha get some of the cinnamon action
boosting out on the side
so my verdict is that America wins
because if there's one thing that our
country does how to do it's not an
injection into food and we have won big
time in the pie category the American as
this high
[Music]